pour la grève bien sûr il aurait
peut-être mieux valu forcer la compagnie
est juste quantité de travail donc on a
commencé on peut pas reprendre avant
d'avoir obtenu justice plutôt crever que
dire qu'on a eu tort quand on a raison
je te crever souhaiter la mort de
personnes ça continue trop longtemps
comme ça c'est nous qui allons mourir de
faim qu'est-ce que tu ta fiche ici je
veux plus te voir battant casser du
sucre pour les enfants c'est bizarre je
pensais donc nous on crève aurait à
faire la grève pour vous continuer le
travail à jean bart ça me dégoûte reste
avec les jaunes aussi avec moi tu t'es
lui quand il veut c'est bien sûr c'est
de vouloir ce concert comment les choses
tournent mal et ça ne s'est pas dit ça
dans les cas notre monde donc on
travaille à jean ba oui tout le monde
travaille les traîtres si tu viens pour
rester c'est bon sinon fils tout de
suite estime toi heureux que j'ai petit
sinon je dors et déjà fichu pied quelque
part